foreign
today
we are facing our faith together
we are facing this fate
while memorizing the illnesses and the
hurts of the pastor while we are fully
intended to meet any challenges
and to of course accept all kinds of
worries
and we are ready to make for a new
future in order to achieve the dreams of
every human being on planet Earth and to
meet his conditions
audacious of course cannot move back
before any necessary change and I have
to say that we are all about the phase
one challenge after another
we are provided with full Spirit of
Victory among the challenge that we are
facing of course
and alternatives
after the second World War
this monetary systems
partitioning the words
it shouldn't have existed in the first
place and it's not acceptable anymore to
continue at these with the same form and
substance
cursor
a full moon
any spot wherever it wanted as well in
Tunisia
we are doing our best to make sure that
a new son will brighten up the whole
word without any discrimination and to
see a new additional and to highlight in
every single spot in the world the light
of Justice of the freedom wherever there
is a human being
another
we are fully convinced that we share the
same feeling that is provided with
responsibilities and we are all
characterized by The Audacity Of The
courageous people to put our heads
together and to act in full solidarity
and simple unity and in fullness
with a view to meeting all the
challenges that we might face no one can
act alone
to meet these challenges
the things for a second that he or she
can
achieve some results
to get closer to each other the peoples
all over the world that are longing for
coherence and foreign
gas
Maritime and transatlantic sovereignty
this is what we detain really dear guess
in this very context and with this High
Spirit that gathers us here and with
these values that we are all share
together
we have signed the mou with the all its
items
a set of
binding agreements starting for the
principles that it's spelled out
and here we are in utmost need for a
Collective Agreement about
inhuman migration and about the
displacements that are masterminded by
some a criminal Network sense the
Tunisian people that provide for all
these displaced migrants
anything if they could expect them with
the full Hospitality with unlimited
generosity whereas so many other
organizations there that should have
played their role in the proper way
should have played their humanitarian
role a good not to move only through
statements
tahal
do you think that these statements will
prevent these migrant people from being
a prey to dangerous and will it provides
them the food and shelter to protect
them against the Heat and against the
coast
this is of course in addition to the
fake news and through the distorted news
in order to disparage and the Tunisian
people and the Tunisian country first
and foremost
and as the poet said
Tunisia to host a conference as the top
level to gather all the states concerned
because the solution to this issue
to the situation
in human situation can only be a common
and a joint one by eradicating its core
reasons before coming coming to the
results
now this is you today but it's also a
reminder that we are fully intended to
implement it in the nearest
time possible thank you once more to all
of you for your attendance
on the land of Tunisia on the land of
the freedom of Justice at the end of the
national dignity
[Applause]
thank you
good evening
ensembly
is
[Music]
stability
in geographical means
of geopolitical answers
[Music]
opportunity
window
uh foreign
[Music]
foreign
an important representative
[Music]
foreign
damage
[Music]
Mercury
foreign
[Music]
results
important
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
sir president and dear colleagues in
team in team Europe I will be relatively
I'm really delighted today
jobs
biggest foreign
foreign
Partnerships
[Music]
history
[Applause]
thank you